[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive so it's time to see
what's making headlines with the daily
mirror economist susie boniface and the
telegraph associate editor for politics
christopher hope they'll be with us from
now right up until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the times reports that sas troops are on
the ground in ukraine for the first time
during the war and are training local
forces in kiev
the eye has spoken to migrants who say
they'll still intend to try to cross the
english channel despite the government's
plan to send some of them to rwanda
the guardian quotes a senior official
from the un refugee agency who believes
the rwanda plan will fail
the telegraph hears that in line with eu
rules speed limiting devices may soon be
fitted to all new cars on british roads
an investigation by the mail has found
that tens of thousands of civil servants
are only working in the office two days
a week despite covered guidance on
working from home being scrapped months
ago
the mirror claims that during their
visit with the queen this week the duke
and duchess of sussex promised they'd
bring their children on their next trip
to the uk
the financial times reports on a
possible strategy that twitter may use
to stop elon musk from buying it in a
hostile takeover
the express says that the good weather
over the easter weekend will generate
two billion pounds for the economy
and the star warns of the dangers of
cold water on hot days at the beach
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by suzy
boniface and christopher hope welcome to
you both uh good to see you let's start
with the guardian
and uh the headline there rwanda plan
will fail that's according to the un
susie you kick us off
yeah so this is uh jillian triggs an
assistant high commissioner at the un
human uh unhcr who says that it's only
going to probably involve a few hundred
people a year at best um and that it's
there's gonna be so many legal
challenges to it that it's not really
gonna work she calls it symbolic more
than anything else and the guardian here
got information about for example uh if
you're going to take things like this to
judicial review there are two appeal
stages if you go through an immigration
tribunal there are three different
stages of appeals
so boris johnson sort of pledged and
promised to try to get people on planes
to rwanda within six weeks
um
you know happily sort of around the time
or shortly after the major local
elections it looks like it's not going
to happen for perhaps two years so
you know those who are suggesting that
this is um a headline grabbing plan to
try to to get some attention ahead of
those local elections when there's
really very little else going for the
conservative party at the moment
um everything else is looking pretty bad
for them
they perhaps have some more meat for
their their arguments now because it
does look like un
high commission refugees are saying this
is just unworkable it's just not going
to get off the ground
christopher is the assistant high
commissioner at the unhcr correct in in
describing the the scheme as symbolic
i can imagine the eye rolling in
whitehall at this ruling from the u.n
the u.n often uh have this way of in
getting involved in in kind of uk
politics in this way which the home
office will just probably think well you
know we expect this i mean the point
about this plan is
it's a plan now there's no other plan
from other similar parties we're yet to
see one from labour um the lib dem
certainly haven't got one this is an
attempt at delivering on the promise of
controlling borders made at the 2016
referendum and that's why it's happening
um the tories think it goes down very
well with its base it goes down very
well with the with the new red wall
seats they won in 2019 and that's the
point of it it's a this is this here
in in a front page piece in the guardian
is the dividing line looking into the
may 24 general election i think it's
really significant what happened this
week um i think is this this is going to
be a debate which um people will be
having for the next two years but
whether it's right and whether even 100
or more than 100 or several hundred make
it to rwanda the point is that that's
almost a side point the key thing is
if it deters little boats coming across
illegally from france it's a success and
that is what will wait and see towards
the end of the year that's worked but we
hear tonight that uh pretty patel the
home secretary has uh put him forth a
ministerial direction which means she's
overruled her uh that's no surprise at
all though
that's no surprise at all because the
way those ministerial directions work
is because the plan is unusual outside
of the box thinking it's costing 120
million pounds it may cost more than
that because it can't be normally uh
scorecarded by the treasury i they can't
work out what it costs the the um
the the chief
it's because it's untested
but that's the point it it is untested
therefore it had pigeon tail had to do a
ministerial direction to get it together
get it through whitehall that had to
happen almost
do you agree with that susie
um i saw some reports uh
over the week in the past few days that
said there has been some modelling but
it isn't being published that makes me
suspicious um although it's the first
time the uk has tried this it has been
tried by other countries in australia
they had about i think about 4 000
refugees were offshored and it ended up
costing about 1.9 million aussie dollars
per head so if they're trying to sort of
what they have modeled if for example
it's based on what israel or australia
did when they are offshoring it's going
to look
worse than they want it to look
certainly that may explain why they're
not publishing it if that has been done
but also the civil servants um who have
said we can't we need a ministerial
direction if you want us to do this
because we can't we can't just go and do
it because it's not value for money
um they have they are bound under the
civil service code of conduct to make
sure they do get value for money for the
taxpayer pretty patel isn't bound by
quite the same promise or the same sort
of guidance although she's supposed to
but so she's just made an instruction
and what i think is really interesting
here is that basically what's happened
is however however well this does or
doesn't work like chris says it could
take two years it could do just six
weeks and then there's a reshuffle and
pretty patel's gone and this whole
policy is in the bin where it belongs
but
it won't however much money is spent on
this between now and whenever it ends
that is money that is the public from
the public purse that could be spent on
something useful
and it's being spent on what is
fundamentally you know a headline
grabbing dead cat
trying to appease the the base and it's
not being based on something's actually
going to work what this policy would do
is end up making sure that people
traffickers can get double bubble out of
every refugee they can try and get
across the channel because they get them
coming up through africa first and then
they get them across the channel again
it gives people an extra incentive to
avoid the authorities once they do get
into the uk that's not what we want we
want people who are genuine asylum
seekers to work and pay tax and be part
of the country and christopher you're
suggesting we could judge the success of
this scheme by
how frequently it deters people crossing
the channel but we read in the eye that
uh channel migrants are worried about
british government's plans to catch them
and send them to rwanda but they say
they will still try to make the crossing
to kent and start a new life
yeah i think this is reports really
important i mean it sets out the
desperation that people feel trying to
get across a channel and that and that
can't that can't be underestimated these
are people who really want to come here
the sudanese man living in a tent in
calais with his wife 28 and son two
tells the eye they will attempt to cross
the channel again after one failed
effort sometimes you arrive
sometimes you die he said and that shows
the desperation
but equally there's frustration in this
country that pretty patel and six and
preceding home secretaries have not done
enough to stop the little boats coming
across and not been enough to deter the
people traffickers and that's why this
dramatic plan is an attempt to do that
and as i say the the proof will be in
the pudding towards the end of the year
and moving to the the the telegraph
running out of time but uh
pretty patel according to the article
running is facing a mutiny from home
office staff unions representing staff
in white were warned of of mass war
counts and transfer requests over the
ethical and legal implications of the
policy
susie
yeah and you know the home office has
been a basket case for years it's not
just pretty patel's fault previous home
secretaries have made a mess of it as
well home office in general is
considered to be a very badly run
department but under pretty patel it
seems to have not gotten anywhere any
better shall we say and perhaps talk
significantly worse and if they're at
the point where people who are working
there are desperate to be just about
anywhere else then you know how long is
it possible for someone whatever boris
johnson may think of her or however much
he may want to reward her brexit loyalty
how long can you keep her in a job where
which is fundamentally to control and to
organize and to to make functional a
very difficult white hall department and
where she isn't doing it and where her
staff are literally running away from
her you know that's the point where you
start you really do have to reshuffle
pretty rapidly after the match or well
or or else susie the problem is with the
home office it's not pretty patel she
may be well she's in charge of it chris
but she but she may be plugged into what
people want she may know more than you
do more than the home or home office do
about what people want to happen which
may be controlling immigration and she
may be responding to that maybe she's
got to control she's the chief executive
she's the boss she's the manager if
they're yeah therefore she's gonna tell
her well if the staff are unhappy it's
her job to get that working properly and
coherently if she can't do it regardless
of politics
the staff have no right not to refuse to
to do
uh government policy they're paid to do
that they can they can leave or take a
transfer as this article says here uh as
the fda david david penman is saying but
the point is that that that that's what
they're there for and
pity patel would definitely argue that
she is doing what was promised in 2016
or as promised in 2019 in the military
manifesto if the physical feels about
doing it for her she'll be doing it on
her own
shortly christopher does it does it it
doesn't bode well for the policy though
does it
well i mean i i think the polling is
encouraging at the moment we've seen a
polling today from electric calculus
find out now saying that 32 percent of
people are in favor 26 against and the
rest don't know about right for a new
policy i wonder whether it might catch
on i wonder whether there's a big
twitter row the usual suspects don't
like it but in fact out there um in in
in britain it may be more popular than
we think
okay christopher and susie for the
moment uh take a break uh cool off
and we'll be back
uh a poll suggests two-thirds of the
public think boris johnson should resign
if he's given any more fines for
breaking lockdown rules we'll discuss
that and more next
[Music]
you're watching the press preview still
with me susie boniface and christopher
hope uh let's take a look at the
times and this yougov poll for the paper
suggesting that uh two-thirds of britons
want the prime minister out if he gets
any more party fines
susie
some people will be thinking only
two-thirds what about the rest of them
others would be thinking who are these
two-thirds of people how dare they
but what's really interesting as with
all polls is when you go deeper into it
so aside from who thinks that he should
or shouldn't resign whether he gets one
two or more fines or anything else only
14
of people polled think he's telling the
truth
14
right more than three quarters of people
think he's lying to us that's quite
massive i've never known that in my
lifetime
and reporting on politics and so on i
don't know if chris has um and there are
68 percent believe he intentionally
misled parliament
um now if that's the case including
heart almost half of all conservative
voters they believe he's intentionally
misleading and that he's lied and i
don't know how anyone in any situation
comes back from that to be
credible at the ballot box i mean
there's all this stuff about boris
johnson and his character and what's
baked in and what is what people voters
already knew about him but to be to
think that in office he's lying to the
public and is lying to parliament and
more than half of everybody thinks that
it's quite
quite a mountain for him to climb uh in
2024 i would suggest and christopher the
stats don't look good apart from the
fine for being ambushed by cake as uh he
described it uh it's thought to have
been involved in at least five of the
remaining 11 events being investigated
by the met
so there's a good chance there could be
another fine
well there's definitely a good chance
that we think at least one of them
a party for a press aid in november 2020
we think he gets fined for that that's
two and there could be as you say four
more
um
yeah it's not a good look at these this
polling i think um the johnson bubble is
well and truly burst we're reporting
tomorrow's telegraph that his face has
been expunged from a lot of tory
leaflets he's he's got what's known as
susie will know it was the jeremy corbyn
treatment for his own party when he
basically just disappeared off the face
of campaign literature because they're
worried about it they're worried about
how this might impact on on the local
elections as as soon as
as early may it's a worry certainly next
week boris johnson will go to the house
to comment on tuesday he's having a mass
meeting of his party with uh susie's
best friend pity patel next door to him
at the meeting to say to his people
there look that was in the past that was
in the past i'm now going to take this
uh this government forward the next two
years and we're delivering on the home
of the immigration pledge with pretty
patel to my right that's the idea and he
will almost
plead with them to give him a chance but
but whether he gets that chance we'll
wait and see there could be a vote as
soon as wednesday on a parliamentary
inquiry into whether he did actually lie
whether he did actually mislead the
house so
he's not out of the woods in any sense
yet it may get a lot worse we shall see
he does seem to be teflon
coated it has to be said but uh let's
see let's move on to the mirror have
just got time to speak about the
sussexes and their surprise visit susie
yes so on their way to the invictus
games in uh holland harry and megan seem
to have had a flying visit to windsor
where they saw the queen and where
russell myers the royal editor is
reporting they told her that they would
get that she would get to see her newest
great granddaughter lillabet sometime
soon now if i was 96 years old and had
been in hospital this year i would like
sooner to have been on this actual visit
not at some indefinite point in the
future i think saying i'm i'm a
relatively big fan of megan's i don't
buy into all the criticism that she gets
but i think if you're going to come and
see the 96 year old great grandmother
you bring the great grandchildren with
you christopher do you think it's a sign
of rifts healing
very quickly
yes i think so i think that any
grandparents in a family like this will
will try and be the bigger person to
recognize things were said that when
maybe shouldn't have been said and it's
all time to move on life is just
literally too short particularly for
routes like this